i am a huge fan of
particularly if you're a beginner or
early intermediate choosing
a repertoire that is based on relatively
off-beat openings and gambits
um i think that's a great idea
and uh what i always advise is that you
know people often ask me you know what
do you think of this opening what do you
think of that opening what should i play
try stuff out
okay you will not be able to
find straight i mean maybe you will
but uh if you're choosing anything uh
that's important to you whether it's an
opening repertoire or
you know uh or clothes i guess or a
house or something you don't usually
choose the first thing that you see you
have to try stuff out see how it works
for you see feel the positions and you
will eventually find something that
feels like home
[Music]
uh but don't over stress trying to make
the correct choice immediately i see a
lot of these questions i'm like i'm
stressed i don't know whether i should
try this opening what is there to lose
you play you lose a couple of three
minute games in a line and at least you
know whether it's good for you or not so
that would be my advice
on
being brave and trying out lines
yourself and seeing whether they work
for your results don't lie
of course having properly studied it you
shouldn't play something without
studying it at all and say well i don't
like it it's bad you're going to hate
everything if you don't know anything
about it
let's go
black against yox
patel
and
let's go e5
and we have a king's cabin
oh absolutely and okay
so
as you guys know if you've been watching
my stream for a very long time
there is a line here that is incredibly
rare i taught it to tori i taught it to
john davis a while ago
does anybody know what move i am
referring to it's not e takes f4
it's not d5 those are very reputable
moves it's not bishop c5 it's a move
that looks completely insane completely
insane
the move potato for president you just
earned yourself i'm going to gift you a
sub
the move is c6
the move is c6 this is one of the rarest
lines against the king's gambit so if
you haven't seen this before you're in
for a treat
i'm not going to say anything about this
move yeah yeah knight f3
basically c6 is a waiting move on
steroids that's what i will say about it
it's a waiting move on steroids you're
basically playing a souped-up carrot con
where white has greatly weakened his
king side with
f4 and now what's the idea the idea is
that you have waited for the knight to
come to f3
which seems to benefit white right like
why are you waiting for white to develop
their pieces
but after d5 the point of the move c6
becomes clear e takes d5 he walks right
into it and now what is the key idea
what should black do
this knight far from being a productive
piece
is now vulnerable to the move e4
then we are able to recover the pawn and
get a monster pawn center with his king
being very very weak knight to e5
and c takes d5 black is in very good
shape here
this should be five check
okay so this is all normal how should we
cover the check
how should we cover the check
yeah knight d7 of course we shouldn't go
knight c6 we should go here and we hope
that he castles this is a very common
oversight a lot of people castle here
they call me a prophet for nothing
all right why is it bad loose pieces
drop off
he's gone f4 he's weak in the diagonal
could be in the b6 winning the bishop
and winning the game
that was a good moment and we take the
bishop oh we could have also unpassanted
first but it it isn't doesn't matter not
necessary
keeping the center closed like this is
also good
okay so we're up a piece all that
remains is for us to consolidate our
advantage a little bit
um where should we bring our queen to
making sure not to give this pawn up too
easily
we should go
queen
no queen d3
queen to a5 that is correct good job
queen to a5
bishop to d2
okay
so what is he threatening he is x-raying
the queen
which means that he's threatening this
move knight takes e4 he is not
threatening knight takes d5 because the
queen will be able to capture the knight
thank you skye gifting to play tao for
president
okay so there's a couple of ways to deal
with this
i think the simplest is to play
uh bishop to b4 yeah covering up the pin
preparing simply to remove this knight
from the board
this is the simplest
a3 bishop takes c3
and now after bishop takes c3 we can
very safely move the queen for example
back to b6 doesn't matter even where
because the pawn on d5 is no longer
hanging
black is up a full piece bishop to b4
okay so he's playing quite resiliently i
have to give my opponent
uh some kudos he's trying his his best
but
well it's not gonna be pretty it's not
gonna be enough
so let's go knight gf6 let's complete
our development then we're gonna worry
about dislodging the bishop he goes c4
okay so we need to be careful we
certainly need to be careful here our
goal is to castle if we can castle short
all of the problems in our position have
been properly solved
unfortunately we cannot castle due to
the due to the bishop on before
preventing it from happening
can we do something about it can we do
something about it
yeah we absolutely can we can use our
pawn and play a5 and basically tell the
bishop to politely or not so politely
get out of there
what should we take with slightly tricky
question guys remember to keep your eyes
on the prize what's the prize the prize
is to castle we want to be able to
castle we want to make sure the bishop
has no squares along this diagonal
and for that to happen you got to think
a little bit outside the box
listen to what i'm saying very carefully
we want to make sure that his bishop
cannot stay on this diagonal because
that prolongs the time that we cannot
castle
let's take with the knight it covers the
c5 square that's the important part if
we had taken with the bishop which of
course is also winning we allow his
bishop uh to park itself on c5 queen
okay so queen a4 is nice
um but it's not going to help him we
have a very classy move here that wins
on the spot because it forces a
transition to an end game remember that
queens just are not very good at holding
things together at accomplishing these
kinds of tasks
and so as odrama la mao says queen to c6
is the move i'm thinking about if we
take the bishop we give up the rook
don't do that
a lot of you guys would take on d4 i
don't like that move either i do not
like queen takes d4 this is a very
important moment
and after the game i'm going to talk
about why that is because
this is a good opportunity to learn
about proper technique going to c6
forcing the queen trade either he moves
the queen back and gives up the bishop
or he must simply take the queen and of
course in the end game i don't even
really care about not being able to
castle
he has this move but doesn't help
okay so
we should consider we can consider
taking on c4 but do we have a better way
of trying to win this pawn
who can find a nice move for black here
bishop to a6 excellent pinning the pawn
to the rook
not giving him any breathing room at all
and trying to get the rest of our pieces
out as quickly as possible just because
it's an end game doesn't mean
uh that you can dilly dally around
c5 okay so he gives this up i mean this
is over
there's yeah so if you want to play
really clinically if you just want to
play
super clinically here not allow any kind
of counterplay any counter play then we
should try to prevent him from going b4
and then maybe b5
so the russian school of chesma was just
to play a4 so that if he plays b4 we
have an on basant
just to make sure that he there's
nothing that he can do he'll probably go
rook b1 and try to get b3 and that would
be my guess
but um it's it's not going to help and
that buys us a little bit of time
right i was about to say un peasant yeah
totally
okay
why is a4 the russian school of chess
because okay so he goes rook b1
um
what i propose we do okay so he still
wants to go b3
our our goal should be to untangle our
pieces such that the rook is able to
enter the game
all right um
so
from that perspective what we can do is
we can just play f5 i i like that move
curious
and the point is to bring the king
around over to f7 and then to e6
in fact we can take on poisson in order
to keep the a file open
and we're just in time to play king f7
he's gonna go here and then we're gonna
walk our king up to e6 protecting the
knight
and then bring the rook into the game
and then infiltrate down the a-file
that's going to be the plan
essentially a way of kind of castling by
hand but we basically bring our king to
the center
and the game is over
now we're threatening to take on a3
thank you gm shadow for the five months
how should we continue in this position
what's the most clinical
what's the most clinical move here we
certainly shouldn't take on a3 because
c6 is hanging we should play
rook h to c8
either forcing a rook trade which is
desirable for us or forcing his rook
back to b7 and then finally we start
taking stuff
i know i'm being a little bit pedantic
here everything is winning but i just
want you guys to experience what proper
technique looks like on this level just
making sure that he has no chances
okay so here if we want to accelerate
the pace at which we give checkmate we
should first and foremost pay attention
to his king
g3
creates empty space on the second ring
which we can essentially use to cut off
his king rook a2 is again the most
clinical move
stopping his king from going anywhere
then we've got essentially two ways to
win the game we can push the e pawn
that's number one
but my preferred method is just to
activate this rook
then move this rook away and basically
try to checkmate him down the a file
okay so he goes back
what we can do here is we can double on
the second rank that's the very
traditional plan that's what we're going
to start with
it really does not matter you could also
trade rooks
okay so here what i'm going to propose
is ah let's just go rook a2 we can
totally ignore everything
take stakes
thank you valentinian have a good night
as well
yeah it's over
the game is over
e3 then we can go like this too we can
get the knight over to e4 i don't know
why he's not resigning to be honest
yeah so i think the simplest here let's
push e3 for just for fun
and then let's go here
no of course it was over 15 moves i mean
it was over after queen b6 in some sense
yeah now we checkmate him with rook h1
in the next move
yeah
okay
yeah i mean
of course this guy blundered pretty
quickly so
this is what it is
oh nice rough assault thank you
that's right phineas
so the move c6 guys is something you're
only going to learn in meredith's
opening laboratory
um
it's it's a move that has been played
now just for reference for context
the main move e takes f4 has featured in
32 059 games
c6 by contrast has only featured in 42.
um and the top rated player to play was
moi in a title tuesday game i played i
played uh this move to crusher gm
a couple of months ago in title tuesday
so uh that i had pretty fond
remembrances of that game
and uh it's it's tremendously rare
why is it so unpopular well it's
certainly not the best move in the
position
and uh be under absolutely no illusions
if you want to play for an advantage
and you want to do it principally in the
king's gambit then you should probably
take the pawn taking the pawn i think
objectively speaking
is the best move and it is the move that
gives black the best chances for an
advantage
um
now of course white plays knight f3 and
now in this position there's a gazillion
different lines
recently
i think 97 has been an interesting
attempt by some grandmaster trying to
get the knight to g6 this is just one of
several lines that i think gives black a
very comfortable game
traditional main line of course is to
play g5 nothing is wrong with this
either it's just incredibly theoretical
and sharp
so from the perspective of avoiding
theory getting an interesting position
c6 is quite good
so first of all f takes e5 is clearly
very bad on account of the typical queen
h4 check
and then either g3 queen if or you know
the drill
knight f3 is
um what the vast majority of
of people play in this position 79 games
uh for knight f3 and
more games have been added via the karo
kano motor so
um and here what you want to do is is go
d5
um this is the whole idea right
this is like a falcor counter gambit
with that knight already on f3
and now our opponent
played e takes d5 which i believe is
not correct
the grandmaster who i played this
against went knight to c3 no if played
right i think it's closer to equality
than anything and now you can simply
play e takes f4
and after takes takes black's got the c6
square for the knight so this is a nice
position for
for black so edc d
and let me just show you a couple of
moves here so johnny played uh the
grandmaster i played this against his
florian jeannie from switzerland he
played bishop e5 check
knight to c6
castles
now of course this does not blunder the
bishop because the bishop is protected
by the knight
um knight uh knight to f6 and already
i'm better because he's not able to
easily win the pawn back knight f64
bishop d6 and i went on to win
this pawn is extra and it's not easy to
win back
so the thing is balzlin asks why is it a
nice position to fly designer
development so that's a little bit of a
simplistic way of looking at the
position
at which point are you asking that
question like in this position or the
way that i showed it here
so yeah so i assume you meant here the
thing is development is only one of
several factors in a position
that white's leading development is
what's called a dynamic advantage or a
temporary advantage
by which i mean if black develops if i
develop my pieces then i'm going to
equalize the situation
but in terms of static weaknesses in
terms of stuff that's a little bit more
permanent white's the one who's done a
lot of damage to his position he's given
up the f pawn which means that the king
side is permanently weak and he's
currently down a pawn
and black's got a very nice central
control so the development advantage
cannot be exploited here black does not
have enough targets black's king is not
sufficiently weak
to allow white to exploit the
development advantage so
it's a temporary advantage that's going
to be equalized once black develops the
pieces no you should hang on to the pawn
if possible in these lines
now the best move is knight takes c5 the
best move is to take on e5 with the
knight
uh this is not something that
a lot of people have done
and uh there's a very this leads to very
interesting complications
uh one of them is after d take e4
bishop c4 happens
and now black has the very nice move
knight to h6 defending the pawn
and so the point is if white simply
castles
this move essentially loses can anybody
tell me why
what happens here
and there is a muppet here most popular
wrong answer there's a tempting move
here several tempting moves but then
there's the correct one
yep and you guys are falling into the
tempting move queen before check is very
tempting but doesn't actually do
anything
because the bishop on c4 is protected by
the knight
instead what you should do
is play the immediate f6
the knight simply has nowhere to go
now perhaps queen h5 check looks a
little bit scary here but if you
calculate the specific line here you
will see that
in fact white's
initiative dissipates
completely
after g6 knight takes g6 there is a key
intermediate move without which white
would have indeed had a lot of attacking
chances in return for the piece last
move that i'll ask you guys to find and
then we'll wrap up soon
what is this intermediate move
that gets the queen away from its x-ray
of the king you still do not need to
play queen d4 you can go without that
move you can play bishop g4 bingo
queen drops back
hg6 and the game is over so all these
subtleties you've got to know if you're
if you are to play align well and the
reason that i'm emphasizing openings
more at this level is that we've hit
1900 as i indicated at the very
beginning of my speed run
i try to
tailor most of my advice
to the level that i'm currently at and
at this level openings have become quite
important you've got to know your stuff
you've got to know concrete lines and
you've got to have some weapons
you've got to have some lines that
perhaps are a little bit more rare that
you can roll out and and win some quick
games that's part of improvement at this
level thank you dai
onla mendaki for the prime
now the way that he played is quite
quite poor
now we get a very very nice position but
still i mean white is not that much
worse here uh if white can play well so
bishop b5 is fine
and of course castles is simply the
decisive mistake here
um
according to my analysis
actually bishop d7 might be a little bit
stronger
but anyways according to my analysis d3
is the only way to preserve
a reasonable position here for white
queen a5 check does not do anything due
to knight c3
um
and if knight and enso black should play
knight gf6
and now white should play the move uh
bishop e3
in order to cover the b6 square and pave
the way for castling
and uh black can play a6 you get sort of
a massive liquidation here a6
bishop takes d7 check knight d7 97 queen
d7
takes takes
and we got an approximately equal
position
so
uh so something like this would have
been a little bit more reasonable
castle's no very common mistake it's
easy to forget that this kind of thing
exists because you don't usually get
this kind of tactic so early the rest of
the game was very obvious bishop before
there was one other instance i wanted to
talk about
which is in this position
why did i not play queen takes d4 chat
so the bottom line here is that our goal
is not to win more pawns we're already
up a piece i've talked about this many
times when you're up a piece or you're
up a significant amount of material
you need to prioritize properly and
oftentimes the priority
is not to take more pawns but to make
sure that you have consolidated your
advantage phineas with a 10 damn girl
oh my goodness
my gosh so many subs today i really
appreciate it man
thank you phineas for the 10 gifted
you are the freaking man
we've got tons of viewers here this is
great to see
uh and and lots of support moving back
up to 5k lovely thank you
uh appreciate all of your
positive company as well
this does not have a name as far as i
know
so back to the point before i was really
interrupted if anybody oh there we go i
was gonna say if anyone wants to
interrupt me with more gifted subs
that's the one interruption that i might
be able to tolerate curious with the
five
damn girl
or i can just sit back and watch people
give me subs that's also great
okay let me try for the third time to
make the point i want to make all right
just trying right now just warning
everybody i'm trying to make another
point here for the third time
um
when you are up a piece you're trying to
consolidate
and sometimes when you start grabbing
more pawns
it makes it harder for you to
consolidate because it might do
something like open up files for your
opponent's pieces
or you might find that a piece which was
responsible for consolidating is now too
busy grabbing pawns and i think this is
the case here now clearly black is still
completely winning
from a computer's perspective queen
takes d4 is undoubtedly the best move if
you turn on the computer you will see a
queen takes d4 check is best by a
country mile
so what the heck am i saying what i'm
saying is that for a human
queen takes d4 presents a lot of danger
because if you for example just grab two
pawns like this watch what happens
rocket is c1 you've already given up the
c file this gets a little bit scary
um it turns out that if you calculate
concretely black is fine here here
bishop d6 and fortunately you have the
move b5 attacking the queen and winning
the bishop but
realistically something like this could
backfire if the circumstances were a
little bit different so if you see an
opportunity to trade queens and emerge
with a full extra piece and you are
absolutely sure
that you've calculated that correctly
that's usually a better practical option
than starting to grab a bunch of pawns
and risking
uh something where
you know where you've given your
opponent too much counter play
i don't know if that makes sense
but that's that's the bottom line here
after king h1 the computer indicates an
insane insane tactical move
that wins this bishop
i i can give you guys a chance to find
it if you want black does have a crazy
move here which turns out to be winning
the bishop
so you cannot move the knight remember
you cannot move the knight
good
the move is b5 good job ready beer
that's crazy b5 is correct
and the thing is if queen takes b5 then
white is no longer pinning the rook
which means that you can now take the
bishop
if white plays c takes b5 then white is
no longer pinning the knight that pawn
is in the way of the pin that means the
knight can move where can it go it goes
to b6 dislodging the queen once more the
queen must move and then you win a
second piece and once you take the
bishop you're able to castle now so the
whole chain reaction falls apart
but of course seeing a move like b5 is
is very very difficult that's a grand
master level move maybe i'd find it in a
classical game
but uh why bother yourself in in the
context of a blitz a rapid game you know
so in any case once we played queen c6
the rest of the game was extremely
straight
forward okay any questions folks before
we wrap up for the night
i think people are pretty clear
i can take just a couple of uh general
questions if people have them
should one play main lines or marginal
and so this is what i addressed earlier
in the stream
what if he takes with a queen yeah so if
he takes with a queen as i indicated
um
b5 so after cb5 you cannot take because
of a takes before i think you missed
that this pawn guards b4
if the queen takes b5 then this queen
was pinning the rook
now it's unpinned you can simply take
the bishop and the rook is untouchable
um
can we bribe you for another game well
you can
so in all seriousness i as i always say
you know i i don't want people to feel
like they're
donating subs or or donating bets just
to get another game i i don't want the
the
the bribing things is fun but i like to
think that people contribute because you
like the overall content not necessarily
because of like
one individual game that i'll play at
the end
and that's what i would encourage people
to do nobody should ever feel pressured
to celebrate to give this up but if you
are doing it
i ask that you do it because you enjoy
the overall content not necessarily
uh because you know right now you want
another game even though i obviously
always try to consider it and i try to
reciprocate when possible
uh thank you for the 100 or the thousand
not
totally not bragging thank you jared i
appreciate it
i know people want more and i always
love to do as much as i can uh and and
i think people deserve the very best
given the level of support so
but at the same time i got to apportion
my energy thank you idcn for the prime
what about the bishop on before
well yeah but that's the bishop that
we're trying to win
okay just looking at some more questions
is playing e5 more theory work than
french or caraca on balance yes
on balance if you want something less
theoretical karo khan at like a beginner
intermediate level is good and the
french is also good now there is a lot
of theory in both of those openings
but e5 is pretty crazy to learn like e5
you have
so many different openings whereas these
other lines maybe even the scandi
sometimes if you're a little bit more
advanced
can definitely be
a little bit more manageable theoretical
theoretically thank you for the thousand
the original black pepper another one
that's crazy thank you sir
um glad to hear that you know how an
apple seed
thank you screws gifting to one more
game
this is hilarious
um do you have any tips for playing one
b3
so recently on chessable uh graham
indian grandmaster bhaskaran adiban
came out with a b3 course that's all i
know
uh you can totally take a look at it i
think it's gonna be good
he does excellent analysis and uh
you know
uh you can consider flirting with that
maybe do one puzzle and explain through
it that's something i'm going to do post
speed run i'm definitely going to
explore
the concept of doing
sort of explained puzzles stuff like
that i want to make that fun and dynamic
so
that's going to take a little bit of
tweaking but i will do my best
um
more content always more content that's
that's the goal that's the goal
what do i think about the ready for i
mean if you like it
again you can try it out if you're if
you're getting good results then
absolutely yeah i would do a chest whoa
screws with a five oh my god screws
gifting five subs oh gosh
i see what you're trying to do i see
thank you thank you
um yeah the dragon is definitely
playable at the highest levels
um
the dragon is definitely playable at the
highest level there's no doubt about
that it's never been refuted
you should consider looking more at
annotated games like
basically uh if you wanna learn from
games there's so many games collections
nowadays that it wouldn't make sense to
try to hunt down on annotated games
thank you jan for gifting to pawn
massour
so
i would say that now i would say
if you are trying to learn from
unannotated games like games that are
played in live tournaments like this you
know let's say you want to analyze the
game that was played in romania in the
grand prix
you know there's multiple techniques for
trying to make sense of it you can look
at the live commentary
which i i suppose is a form of
annotation you can
um you can use the engine
and uh that's a whole separate thing
analyzing with an engine
and being able to learn from that
analysis is a difficult task and i might
do like a specific lecture on that as
exhaustive gifting five
oh my lands
i like positional chess and i've been
playing d4 c4 for white what would be a
good position well
against e4 or d4 that really depends i
mean car okanagan c4 is the classic
positional opening and queen's gambit
decline or slav against d4 is is pretty
good against d4
no i use the physical board i like using
the physical board
um
will the afternoon stream be the speedo
i cannot promise that i i i don't know
again i i prefer it if
people just sort of roll roll with it
and
i try to do at least a little bit of
speed on every stream
but occasionally i get into a good blitz
match or something like that and
you know then the plans have to change
um
no i i didn't mean the karo kind of
against c5 i know the karo khan against
e4
why isn't the vienna more con because
black equalizes quite easily in the
vienna with best play
but
i think that the vienna is one of the
best openings at any level really below
2200
so
i'm a huge proponent of viviana for a
lot of different types of players
and that would be what i'd say how do
you train night movements as a beginner
well
you just kind of have to play like
i'm not sure if you could really do
isolated work on
particular piece moves maybe there are
some resources out there i'm not a i'm
not the best person to ask on like
modern resources for beginners simply
because i don't train with too many
beginners these days and when i started
playing chess
the landscape was completely different i
mean the internet existed and stuff but
there weren't nearly as many resources
for beginners as there are now on
youtube and on various chess sites so
you're gonna have to do some digging by
yourself
and i would say that don't
feel you know don't hold back if you
like search youtube search
search twitch you know find a streamer
that does instructional stuff there's so
much stuff out there just gotta find
whatever works for you and youtube is a
tremendously
uh amazing repository for
for chess content there's so much good
stuff out there there's lectures
and some of them aren't very well known
like all sorts of gm's have delivered
lectures on various topics that's all to
be found on youtube
uh you know
nobody's gonna lead you by the hand on
these things you're going to have to
find it yourself but
but you can always try to find the
instructor or the type of content that
works for you that's something that i
would say is very important i've tried
to make the speedrun into a format that
works for everybody no matter your
learning style
but in terms of other types of content
there's videos there's books
try everything and see
how you're able to transfer your
knowledge most directly that's what i'd
say thank you all thank you for hanging
out um and thank you for all the support
i'll see you guys later have a great
night morning wherever you are take care
bye
[Music]